do you want to talk about jesus and
marrow splitting up yeah man that's
unfortunate it's sad yo it's sad because
we've known them since what it's a guy
code guy code yeah yeah and i didn't
know how big they were until we did an
ama for like the first season of guy
code or whatever
andrew was there and i assumed all the
questions would be them and so many
jesus and mural questions and the
saddest thing is the friendship seems
like it's [ __ ] up that's what it seems
like like it doesn't seem like it's
amicable to me that's the saddest thing
and that's like
bro that's i always think about that
with this like the friendship always we
always say to each other the friendship
gotta come first that that is gonna come
first if it ends amicably hey
everybody's happy this is what was best
if it ends with the friendship going
sour yeah [ __ ] dude that's something
else if you nurture the friendship then
usually the business relationship will
be good yeah but it does get harder
because you get busier and then the work
becomes the friendship and then you have
to like it's like a relationship you got
to like make time that made me like yo
we gotta like get dinner or something
because you don't get time anymore 100
and like i think one thing that we have
that's just very beneficial is that we
both have things outside of this thing
yes
yes so like stand up
like and i wonder if
them not having that was also
difficult i mean i don't know but like
the idea that you have your own thing
or
like even having brilliant idiots like
another thing that i'm doing outside of
this yeah so that there are kind of a
your your your identity is
is nourished in that way as well and we
started with that so when we step out or
when you start you're still doing stuff
on your own if you start together yeah
and then one of you steps out and does
your own thing the other person might be
like yo what the [ __ ] you know yeah
leaving me yeah yeah this is understood
stand-up is our love we're gonna do that
all the time yeah so i think that helps
for sure yeah having that like thing
that you're passionate about
yeah
stand up is the [ __ ] bruh but also just
like having like having a thing that
you're passionate about and then
everything else is serving that yeah is
so valuable when you're like in you know
entertainer or whatever like
because
if you're if you're an entertainer for
entertainer's sake that's tricky though
yeah you might not get them movie roles
no more right and then you might have to
accept movies you don't like or don't
want to do so you could get something
right where it's just like
as as a stand-up like you get to do your
jokes that crowd might suck yeah it
might be a shitty venue on the road but
it's still the thing you want to say in
the thing that you want to do you write
the script exactly that is the passion
and there's a muscle that you're working
on i guess if you do a shitty movie you
can like work on the muscle of acting
within that movie but like
we never have to do the lines that we
don't want to do or we don't believe in
yeah and like having that thing and now
i'm really missing a stand-up but like
having that thing
i don't know it's just really
like as an entertainer like
for me i could always feel successful
even if success isn't there because i'm
working towards the thing that i love
the most and that's within my control
yeah
whereas if you're an actor if you're
even a musician and people don't like an
album and now you're like [ __ ] man like
yeah what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do i
might not even have the opportunity to
do another it's like i guess with music
you could just make your music mm-hmm
that's i never maybe it's more
vulnerable if you're just like an
entertainer
like where fame is the goal yes not art
is the goal maybe that's a more nuance i
understand that thing that we always
joke about why people tell their kids
like do what you love i get do what
you're passionate about because you can
throw yourself into that completely and
be fulfilled if you're passionate about
even acting like you said i can take
this shitty role and i'd be passionate
about my craft and work on my craft if
if my passion is just i want to be
famous yeah you're not going to feel
full ever so we're very fortunate in
that sense that we're passionate about a
thing we can just go work on and that's
it i don't need anything else